hello my name is markiplier and welcome
back to mr. Musashi the totally platonic
and not sexual in any way game about
meeting people who are very normal and
not weird and having a great time with
them and I don't know why I'm getting
louder it's okay anyway I'll getting
back in yeah we're getting back into mr.
Musashi because for some reason you guys
wanted a lot more of this game and I'm
not 100% sure why on its surface it
didn't seem to you know not sexual
anyway so I'm just gonna I can't
remember how to play no no no no no no
no no no kill Chuck Venegas kill dock
out and kill Doug kill dock is right
there dead duck that's not under
pretended dead duck right in the corner
my goddamn screen I can't exactly say it
any other way than that this is a dead
duck Holmes anyway whatever no no it's
Martha I got a date with Martha I'm
looking for a sexy man I love traveling
that's how I roll alright man you seem
never mind then James profile alright
then how about this this sexy guy my
phone looks like a guy on your screen
it's me yeah well if I I don't know it's
a match you and Martha likey I forgot
about the transformation from score in
the first date where blue research is
showing the women are attractive men in
blue unless you like Johnny then you
fine no matter what you wear and you're
also flashing rainbow who dances through
the sky has babies with aliens anyway
Johnny is having an online date with
Martha
okay all right then I'm Arthur
I took how's it going so right hey you
have a cute nose uh thank you you have a
cute actually you're next you at all hey
wait a minute you look nothing like your
probiotic you'll be silly let their
profile pic is drawing not a photograph
can you tell the difference between
reality and fiction ah but that is the
cartoon for me from when I was 19 when I
worked as a lingerie model okay Oh
jiggly are you Stuart for de Qi and
banana did I tell you that already the
commission that picture from some famous
French guy but I got lost in Paris
shortly after okay this story makes no
goddamn sense at all I just got into
this game and I don't understand a
single thing that you're saying okay I'm
getting misogyny points let me put that
drawing on the milk cartons within the
paper
oh man was that a weird couple of days
maybe travel all around the world you
know you wouldn't know about look at me
now wow that sounds like a lot of BS to
me except I'm wearing blue today so you
age like fine wine that's too jiggly for
my taste you need to back down a little
bit there you're as charming as a
freshly baked baguette baguette don't
have personalities no matter how many
times they say bonjour to you I believe
I have a couple of stories from my
modeling days for you oh please
enlighten me do I have a choice after
being in Paree I was called for a
hamburger modeling photo session I was
with my boyfriend at the time so I
occasionally do a red bikini and I had
to sit on the sticky black couch then
this hunky guy comes with him and dips
mckubre grrrrrr Oh
well I found creepies that they were
filming the whole thing and I'm like
tweet up what's going on here and they
started asking some funky stuff right
turns out there so we get independent
movie those in the wrong room
as I ever lucky that my ex was around he
saw the couch and said we had to leave
can't think what got into him okay where
I've been hey hey I got a black out you
uh eat burgers on me
maybe hamburgers aren't my thing don't
you know Oh little jiggly well I can
make an exception just for you
hoody waffle oh god you need to stop
that I believe we can hang out for a
while and laugh a lot sure pick you up
in my truck ironically enough I'm
transporting couches and grills today
well lovely coincidence we're having on
this wonderful date that we're having
here oh boy as a tiny jiggle just for
the road and I can just bet there's a
black couch somewhere in there see you
tonight Johnny honey all right okay
burgers and chill that seems a hot boy
all right see how this massage is a low
deep Rumble okay all right okay not
weird at all ah no okay this is it this
is quite this it's kicked into overdrive
ah hey hey hey now that's getting the
muscles
that's relieving all my stress yep
that's a good massage thanks all right
I'm gonna leave now
hey Dad looking good
good on Nouwen mama's jelly all flown in
hence the massage II for real continue
to
lovely dating adventure no I'm good
Sarah alright my profile and cycling
back around hang on hang on hang on
there we go
I fear oh yeah you like winners baby I'm
the best biggest winner that you ever
won and the prize is movie couldn't you
imagine how great I am
Oh only all the time thank you a
Valentine's Day 15 percent of women in
the US and themselves flowers johnny is
in the wacko lounge
Sarah's right next to him okay hi Sarah
how you doing you run holding back belly
you want it sounds familiar
did I run into it's an area like this in
huniepop one time to lose my virginity
see you're beautiful and pretty and I
really want to dare you Wow nothing said
nothing wrong about being direct what
huh you know what [ __ ] off what I'm a
winner baby but I'm a winner
baby I'm a winner baby baby I'm a winner
so how much of a winner I am see but
it's a winner I'm sorry alright let's
add again alright hey baby
do I got a match this give it here
havock I've lost it I can't find it have
you seen it
yeah flight mr. Shi I believe you
I'm Sarah I guess you knew that already
man this is this place boring as [ __ ] or
what yeah I'm getting a lot of huniepop
vibes from this how about I get you a
mojito it's on me that's cuz that's what
we're not danced baby because when
Margot Meyer starts dancing the whole
plate sets on fire
twon fan from 13 clubs around the globe
oh [ __ ]
we're not dancing you're joking you're
joking right I hate to dance
did you even read my profile no I didn't
not at all look I just want something to
drink
we sure wish you were a mojito at least
you'd be good for something
Johnny Boz they're a fine mosquito area
damn that's so good it places the best
mojitos good call I forget your name
don't you dare think that my panties are
going off now you get one chance
what are you for fun Oh win are you I
help orphans puppies I help orphan bees
so you're an animal nanny booth yeah
that's me I love them a lot in addition
to all the unprotected sex and rock and
roll I had a puppy one for the diet I
think good yeah you're kind of burly
heck yeah glad you don't don't have any
brains but I got a lot of brawn how big
are you well you know about five foot
ten you know God religion is a [ __ ] how
big do you want depends on I think do
you want me to be baby I think you want
me to be ah right I really don't want
anything
the monkey [ __ ] off this is getting
boring I'll be right back or whatever
just are you with a stranger at the bar
I'm a bit of a loser there's still the
boys just dancing the crap out of the
10th floor
oh yeah Johnny don't stop dancing for
nobody Johnny just won a prize for his
exotic moves he won $500 well yeah well
hey I mean nice to see you again dude so
what you're going to do with all that
money uh save it in the banks with the
rest of my fortune
fortune yeah you totally look like a
smart man I can make it fortune did I
tell you uh how lovely your earlobes are
thank you I've been waiting for someone
to notice how lovely my earlobe is I
mean I don't want to sound interested we
just met but I feel like we belong
together
isn't that like so crazy oh my god meet
you I'm in love marry me just playing
around but how many mojitos could buy me
huh like with your whole fortune huh I
can buy like this many dad many we can
buy I'd buy them all
I buy the world supply Mohit for you huh
what are you a cop I'm funny
did I mention I'm funny that was on my
profile right the fact that I'm funny
hope you got that
come on man don't be such a smartass you
know I'm totally kidding right a man
once I was dating this rich [ __ ]
claiming to be the inventor of Twatter
social internet thing for complaining
publicly turned out the Twatter was
banking it was a business of cocaine
cocaine transported truck containers but
only on Mondays I'm bored out of my mind
as a story crazy us and then his wife
found out about us and killed him with
the spoon it was like
raaagh and I never heard from him again
in the end I guess he achieved something
in his life did me how about you dude
what's your grant victory ah man I
invented linger you mean V linger yep
made by Steve sucker Gates cuz I call
[ __ ] on your story oh my now with
that nerd wire
he got so addicted to his virtual
reality crap that he wasn't interested
in real human contact anymore anyway go
stick your head in the toilet kitchen
full crap well this went about as well
as I could have expected I didn't expect
anything to go better than anything else
my life that's gone this way thus far
what was I to hope that love would find
me I mean a massage not anything do with
love or anything or anything sexual it's
all about the massage anyway could chair
you yeah all right yeah I got it I think
you put this one on I got to go back to
my booty pop date put on my mark a
douche moe
remember pop collar up the department
hey sup it's me good mark you can call
me that if you want maybe I don't know
yeah
give me that yeah that's right ok ok
sure you know what yeah I'll go get you
mojito
uh yeah cookie okay yeah I know it's
good yeah whatever
it's good right unprotected sex that's
me on the man you know what I do not
safe stuff I rob banks with like two
guns it's nuts
I'm crazy wild even I've got no morals I
didn't ask
I like avocados they got the good fat
you know normally I'm very raunchy but
today I think I want to go first three
avocado you're kinky
not bad for a virgin oh I know I've been
told that many times each and every time
I lost my virginity everyone was like
whoa hey you're good and then you know
life was better for me after that yeah
you know you kind of Pearlie I know work
out lots of roid that's nothing but true
how big are you job big real big
face big you ever big step big you're
still trying too hard
all right well okay all right well go to
beauty bunny that's what I got locked up
it's got a fortune a hell yeah oh oh
yeah oh yeah what I put that was my
douchiest all right this time mega
douche mode coming in hot and heavy fast
and strong virginity out the window
completely gone premiere you know what
else booze I've got it all over you free
no question sex drugs love them cocaine
I got mad my comma on the hookup I'm big
so big you know our big depends on the
temperature got a balmy out today means
I'm big
okay all right okay fortune yes that's
right
fortune how rich too rich for words they
don't have a number for how much money I
have and you don't have a number for how
much massage I'm going to give you ah
I'm the Employee of the Month every
month that's for reals that's impressive
sound like a box of secret I know you're
all sounds like a box of Secrets my dick
I don't know I want to open that box
more ways one how could you be so
accomplished I mean Wow Employee of the
Month every month I know hard to do I'm
the only employee kind of self-employed
here and I get to pick who gets to be
that one didn't win it one day for chica
chicas dog don't worry about that we get
to that later
I'm just passed I'm the best we're gonna
say I got more than good and best yeah
Oh triple musashi oh I'm already
prepping I'm ready
bring it on ready I've got a deep not
that you need to relieve a point I
didn't see the question again I'm a
little 28,000 League of War clash a big
called cookie Phoenix rage Oh what was
the question can I go back step nap
can't do that well here we go I know the
capital Costa Rica no no that's a lie
there we go okay cool you do sports or
something oh I don't want to brag on the
best sports I got one arm at Tom Brady
one arm at Tyler both too powerful for
command kind to comprehend you want to
see them you'll see you see my bulging
biceps right ready Tom Brady Tyler
together they pork a loving come
I'm admired by my peers for my social
and political viewpoints an outstanding
website well that's not goddamn true
apparently I don't mean to brag when I'm
world champion dead audio the bottom one
oh that's pretty cool I guess it takes
strong mind a people to listen to oh
yeah if you yell as loud as I do
everyone's gonna listen no matter what
you say I love persuasive men a man that
can take what he wants and make others
thanking for it hell yeah that's me I
don't return my videos to Blockbuster
cuz Dead all of it you know what dude
sweep me off my feet let's do whatever
you want tonight
oh heck yeah next morning Johnny mo
should be oh wait you're great Boston
thought was amazing I know you don't
need to tell me I'm worried about
amazing I am I'm sold amazing have you
seen how amazing I am got to wait nice
lolly this massage feels slightly crazy
and manipulative and exploitative I
don't know what it is
I feel more stressed if anything after
getting this massage the sloppy hand we
all know you like it I don't I think you
know what I like even I don't know what
I like who the heck are you Dorothy
I'm new in town looking for a
gentlemanly tour guide high heels I'm
happy I'm a great listener baby have you
heard how great I listen about you Oh
Dorothy oh man love listen according to
studies there's a link between danger
nomadic attraction go skydiving on your
first day
okay johnny is gonna Boulevard cafe be
ambience and cozy but chilly
Oh
you're a cow alrighty then I'm Dorothy
you must be Johnny I'm quite new in this
idiom not used to be dating machines or
whatever holy cow talking cow oh
whatever
how rude Johnny I know I'm a little
overweight which is most sensible ways
to say that are you a gentleman good day
to you sir
welcome let me try that again with a
little ice sorry
besides it's on my neck room I don't
know a [ __ ] reason and I still had
douche mode turned on let me turn on
suave oh did you know that I'm French oh
yes it's cute I know dear do you don't
talk too much do you
that's okay I like well sir well then as
I was saying oh you're different
I'm a bit new to the city so far people
have been staring curiously at me well
but that is to be expected from a more
rural kind of girl teehee however I
won't let that small nuisance bring me
down I fully intend to have a lively
time here that's my story shortener
symbols
whoo-hee oh ma cherie don't you - you
unlock - you are I see you're lucky with
that Farley clutter in your heart do you
want to get lucky with me die excuse my
feet we like come from the farm
why that's admirable not quite my job
but it was close
however did you deduce I used to work on
a bond getting up at 4:00 am sleeping in
length not a great lifestyle for a lady
if you ask me right now I'm searching
for a new job in the city something of
this less demeaning than getting real
I definitely wish something more suited
to my face
Oh naturally how I wish to drag from of
your peers
haha it's late yeah you hold it here you
how oh no more
I just want to hear about your emotion
all day long
tell me what did you do to bother me but
you do that you do that as some friends
told me I'm quite dexterous with my
hands yeah I'm in meetup in this house I
didn't mean to close now I'm blushing
but it's true
I'm quite the needlework expert huh good
thing your good work with needles then
you know ah [ __ ] merely by looking at me
what would you say is my best talent ah
how I could not believe how the talents
that you have in your boosts I offer I
bet I bet I wish I wish you promised
sour sour
[Music]
yes your talent is on he cut that beauty
you're cute paste faster than child
excuse my mix of German and French here
though I know how utterly charming hon I
must be blushing like a schoolgirl
I can see only hope people in the city I
like you oh no no there's no one in a
positive like me over what am I saying
it's barely known city yeah I most
certainly need a guy we please take me
someplace nice
oh good
there's the lovelies talk lot underneath
the ISIS power where all can marvel at
your beauty even understand I am rock
structure of it the sturdy iron rock
rock shell of the Eiffel Tower can't
compare to the beauty of you're born oh
my
a picnic how utterly delightful why are
you love open spaces and lush garden
such places make me feel right at home
but better but I don't think I've seen a
park around here since I arrived
oh wait a moment I'm afraid I have no
money for this trip Paul not surely do
you not know that I just one had Honda
leave Alice and the only - one more
people I'll expect every dollar I've
eaten yeah I don't particularly have a
job as it yet so sad
no well it's bad you don't know Oh
Johnny you such a gentleman I simply
must treat you to dinner after I find a
suitable job shall we get going then
that all fair dinkum you can be better
than this man I try my best
it's not just enough friends ah
wait I can do better but it's going to
be the expedited French version oh wow
factor
what do you pair that vault I have all
day to find out picnic not for changing
the comic what do you have in mind for
the job to become flex silly dream job
of mine maybe not so but it's most
certainly confusing deceased I would put
a small child on my father purchased a
television set
we don't give that sort of thing very
often watching movies was mother late at
night all those novels ah silly
ah but I dreamed of becoming a movie I
never really did sitting with my
family's habits eventually I strived for
a more realistic goal for my capability
to be I was quite skillful with the
selling shoe
i stitched my own garments and wanted to
model mother was most definitely
approving father eventually allowed me
to have a more leisurely lifestyle
I even purchased an old computer good
enough to tinker around with I
discovered fashion on the interwebs
you loved it so it's luck what happened
my goal shifted yet again from a model
to a fashion blogger where oh if I never
saw a more first life blob there then
the one that you have on here I would be
remiss to ever notice that delicious
that lies with your thighs Oh such
flattery this how you usually talk to
ladies no I never pull out the French
Irish German for anybody but expression
being new here being prey to the
malicious stares exchange you can make
oneself lose confidence feel rather safe
with you my massager is about to fall
down I feel rather safe among other
things I feel goo hee hee
shall we you're going I wish to be
someplace alone with you oh here we go
ready Oh without your hat you look quite
beautiful
Oh glob lust I'm is just entire to me
wrong I can't yeah Mozza I don't know
what acting I'm doing now I'm gonna drop
the French hey baby nice cow ass why I'm
out of here
okay that's a good joke to end this on I
think I can live happily with my life
choices now and sleep soundly at night
anyway Oh probably all for this episode
of mr. Masada
I think there's four people to swoon
left so um yeah I'll probably finish
this one out
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know you saw this and let me know
what you thought of my French accent
down the comments below be honest it was
great wasn't it anyway so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]